[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je dis 18 octobre
bienvenue dans le 7-8 journal sur tv
60,18 l'essentiel de l'actualité locale
en 26 minutes
tout de suite les titres de cette
édition un forum emploi dans un centre
commercial il était organisée
aujourd'hui au sein de l'espace saint
quentin à montigny le bretonneux
plusieurs enseignes présentes sur le
site proposait des postes plus d'une
vingtaine d'offres dans le secteur des
métiers du commerce
ces salariés cours pour la bonne cause
la quatrième édition des marcassins du
coeur se déroulait à la mi journée trois
courses à guyancourt dont un trail de 10
km est les profits seront reversés à
trois associations les restes du coeur
les dunes d'espoir et l'enfant bleu
enfin c'est en ce moment octobre rose le
mois de sensibilisation au cancer du
sein des associations se mobilisent à
cette occasion le gb plaisir s'associe
par exemple au programme gym après
cancer les cours débuteront en novembre
et puis invité dans ce journal olivier
devaux nouveau directeur du cfa de la
chambre des métiers de l'artisanat des
yvelines les locaux du centre ont été à
tout récemment rénové à la recherche de
leurs futurs employés c'est l'objet du
forum de l'emploi
l espace saint quentin 7 enseignes du
centre commercial ont participé à cet
événement en partenariat avec pôle
emploi et saint quentin en yvelines
reportage de nicolas landry
devenir vendeur conseil dans cette
enseigne de l'espace saint quentin 2
emplois recherchés par la responsable du
magasin nathalie leber un cdd pour la
période de noël est un cdi à partir du 4
novembre et vendeurs les vendeurs
conseil
[Musique]
et on fait de la mise en rayon mais on
fait aussi du l'accompagnement qui
hantait nous saisir la personne à rendre
dans la boutique on l'accompagné jusqu'à
la fin de sa vente
c'est vraiment intéressant de pouvoir
avoir directement les managers dans des
magasins et la rentrée dans son vendeur
server manager ou employés de rayons les
différents postes à pourvoir lors de ce
forum organisé ce jeudi 18 octobre au
coeur de l'espace saint quentin au total
près de 25 emplois recherchés par cette
enseigne du centre commercial un
événement organisé par pôle emploi saint
quentin en yvelines le centre commercial
et la cité des métiers
l'objectif pour la cité des métiers
c'est bien sûr de participer à la vie
économique du territoire autant du
couteau fin pour les enseignes qui ont
des besoins en recrutement que pour les
demandeurs d'emploi où toutes les
personnes salariées étudiants qui
rechercherait un emploi dans ces
domaines
l'idée effectivement du montage de ce
forum est le choix de la date correspond
à un calendrier pour les anciennes
l'idée c'est que les enseignes puisse
avoir un vivier disponible pour les
fêtes de fin d'année bien puisque un cv
ce sont les compétences qui sont mises
en avant les compétences des candidats
et la transférabilité de ses compétences
sur différents postes
on est sur les savoirs l'usiné savoir
être et les savoir faire
près de 200 personnes sont venues sur le
forum pour déposer leur candidature
l association des marcassins du coeur a
organisé aujourd'hui la quatrième
édition de sa course solidaire le départ
s'est effectué à la mi journée devant le
siège de sodexo partenaires de
l'initiative le siège de sodexo qui est
à guyancourt 350 salariés ont donné de
leur temps à la pause déjeuner les fonds
récoltés iront à des associations
caritatives
retour sur ce rendez vous avec manon
varaldo enzo quatre ans est atteint
d'une maladie neuromusculaire à la
myasthénie congénitale il prend part à
cette course grâce à une geôle est un
fauteuil tout terrain
c'est la première fois que sa mère cindy
peut courir à ses côtés
c'est un combat de tous les jours
un traitement mais le côté au quotidien
ça ne l'aide pas c'est ça le guérit pas
en fait ça va l'aider à marcher il va
marcher deux minutes
voilà c'est un combat de tous les jours
il ya les soins il ya eu dernièrement
une gastrostomie pour pouvoir être
nourri par l'estomac
cette course solidaire s'est déroulé
pendant le temps du déjeuner afin de
permettre à des salariés de participer
350 salariés cours pour la bonne cause
trois parcours étaient proposés c'était
10 km c'est vrai très rapidement il ya
pas mal de monter donc on est rapidement
surpris mais en fait au final ça va ça
se fait c'est dans un cadre très
agréable et c'est vrai que quand c'est
la pensée pour la bonne cause
autant forcer l'intégralité des profits
de cet événement sont reversés aux
associations les restes du coeur
l'enfant bleu et les dunes de l'espoir
l'idée de départ qu'on a eu c'est en
gros
de créer un événement solidaire et
sportif solidaire c'est à dire on prend
l'argent mais on reverse la totalité de
ce qu'on a et on garde de rien pour nous
en trois éditions les marcassins du
coeur ont reversé plus de 15000 euros
cette initiative s'adresse aux personnes
qui sont ou qui ont été touchées par le
cancer après les vacances de la
toussaint l'association gv et plaisir
proposera des cours et gym après cancer
pour parler de cette initiative sa
présidente marie claude jerry bonsoir
bonsoir
il est donc la présidente du gvt et
plaisir alors juste avant de songer au
nastic volontaire depuis six gymnastes
volontaires de plaisir vous faites bien
de le préciser alors juste avant de
présenter ce programme l'association se
mobilise chaque année à l'occasion
d'octobre rose mois de sensibilisation
au cancer du sein de quelle manière vous
n'autorisez alors on se mobilise c'est à
dire que on participe à différents
événements nationaux comme odyssea
imagine fort margot on mobilise donc les
troupes pour venir à cet événement et
puis on s'habille aussi dans la salle
tous les participants aux courses à vie
en rose
bon maintenant on met aussi une urne
pour récolter des dons
pourquoi c'est important pour vous de se
mobiliser en ce moment c'est important
parce que notre fédération qui est la
fédération française d'éducation
physique et de gymnastique volontaire
depuis 25 ans tu portes le concept sport
santé et elle a mis au point en 2011 un
programme qui s'appelle donc gym cancer
et nous dans notre social sociation il
nous tient à coeur de pouvoir aider ces
personnes dans la maladie parce qu'on
sait très bien le corps médical le
témoigne que faire une activité physique
adaptée durant la maladie aide à
supporter les traitements permet aux
gens de sortir de chez eux donc de
rompre l'isolément et vise 50% des
récidives permet de retrouver confiance
en soi et de se réapproprier son corps
et nous dans une association que la
nôtre qui est très importante qui à
bientôt 40 ans d'existence
on se devait de porter ce ces séances
pourraient dit ces gens là on va
reparler du concept dans un instant lors
votre club vous le disiez est affilié à
la fédération française d'éducation
physique et de gymnastique volontaire
il n'y a pas de compétition on est
vraiment sûr sur du sport santé balles
en mission
sport santé du sport de loisir en fait
notre fédération est la seule en france
qui s'adresse à tous les publics des
petits bébés qui commence à 12 mois par
de la gym câline gym douce gym bébé et
on va jusqu'au très grands seniors et
aux activités physiques adaptées et là
on est en plein dans le sport santé avec
ce programme gym après cancer quel est
le principe alors le principe vinci que
les gens déjà je voulais dit tout à
l'heure se réapproprient leur corps
retrouve confiance en eux sortent de
chez eux donc c'est rompre rompre l
isolement
en fait ils ont besoin de parler aussi
ensemble de leurs problèmes et puis nous
bat on les aide à travers une activité
alors il ya une séance en salle d'une
heure le lundi et une autre à
l'extérieur parce qu'à l'extérieur elles
font de la marche un peu de dynamique à
la salle vasse et de l'oxygénation c'est
de la relaxation c'est de l'equilibre en
fait c'est tout ça qu'on travaille un
peu de renforcement musculaire mais
c'est de la gym adaptée en fonction un
peu du 4 chacun et pour les personnes
qui sont atteintes du cancer n'y a aucun
risque à pratiquer du sport peut être au
contraire il ya des bienfaits ils ont
rasé la ville contre le cancer qui nous
les envoient et en fait les médecins
sont unanimes les oncologues aussi pour
dire qu'une activité physique aide les
gens justement dans la maladie en phase
de rémission aussi ça peut être un plat
pour repartir
la pratique alors voilà galles
l'objectif c'est déjà au début du
traitement
c'est d'essayer de les mettre dans une
activité physique pour que il sera
approprié leur corps et tout ça mais à
la fin du traitement notre objectif à
nous c'est que ces séances devienne une
passerelle pour qu'ils puissent ensuite
intégrer d'autres activités au sein du
club
d'ailleurs vous le disiez il ya des
aspects psychologiques des bienfaits
psychologiques aussi physique
oui oui oui les gens en fait témoigne du
fait que finalement bah oui se sentent
mieux dans la vigne dans leur corps ils
se mettent à bouger et ils ont envie de
continuer en fait c'est ça qui est
formidable
quand vous le disais deux séances par
semaine selon pour l'instant nous avons
fait de deux heures par semaine et ce
qui est pas mal déjà et et comment vont
se dérouler ces séances
justement alors comment elles ont existé
déjà de l'or ce que je veux dire si on a
fait une petite interruption
parce qu'en fait notre animatrice qui
étaient certifiés gym cancer a eu 10
si physique dont elle ne peut plus
animée donc on a deux animatrices qui
partent en formation à la fin du mois
d'octobre et on va redémarrer les
séances mais les quatre personnes qui
sont déjà chez nous ont intégré des
cours de stretching de relaxation de
pilates pour qu'on continue à les
conserver de la marche active des cours
en intérieur ou en extérieur les
différentes mais qui sont elles ont
besoin d'aller dehors de marché d'avoir
un peu d'oxygénation est chose comme ça
t'en liddell j'imagine c'est de pouvoir
suivre tout le programme de novembre
jusqu'à fin juin pour aussi observer les
bienfaits la révolution bel et bien sûr
la progression mais après ce sont des
gens qui ne sont pas toujours assidu
puisqu'ils sont à suivre
à suivre des traitements donc ils
viennent quand ils peuvent quand leur
corps leur permet aussi mais bon nous on
les a et puis on voit progresser on y
voit que le sourire et ça nous fait
plaisir et c'est les cours qu'on peut
rejoindre toute l'année même si on vous
rejoins descendre s'inscrire tout au
long de l'année et bien sûr le site this
affichant pour toutes les informations
vous parliez des animatrices celles qui
y voit là vont diriger ces séances et
des animatrices qualifiées sur sur ce
programme gym après cancer voilà alors
donc toutes nos animateurs ont un
diplôme certifié fédéral national mais
pour animiste genre de séance il faut
effectivement une formation spécifique
c'est une formation dati pour les
activités spécifiques adaptés des
questions pratiques comment fait-on pour
s'inscrire on va sur notre site internet
de la gb plaisir ou sur facebook et puis
on regarde des informations le planning
les séances tout est indiqué pour
s'inscrire une licence grosso modo ça
coûte combien
alors pour la gym cancer ça doit coûter
80 à euros l'année + licence assurance a
fait 122 euros l'année pour deux heures
par semaine et du coup ces séances qui
sont voilà qui sont suivis au sein de
votre association est ce qu'il ya une
suite après est-ce que vous suivez les
personnes qui ont pu avoir ces cours ben
oui alors en général les gens sont
fidèles ils reviennent et d'autres ont
intégré d'autres séances
maintenant je les retrouve en stretching
on les retrouve en relaxation on le
retrouve en pilates ou on
active oui oui bien sûr rappelez nous
reste une minute les cours débutent à
après les vacances de la toussaint les
cours vont démarrer à partir du lundi 5
novembre
oui et toutes les informations les
retrouve je le rappelle jv plaisir faire
il s'affiche voilà en même temps en même
temps que votre annonce merci marie
claude jerry d'avoir été avec nous
président du gvt et plaisir gymnastique
volontaire de plaisir qui proposera donc
après les vacances de la toussaint est
des cours gym après cancer
un nouveau marché aux clayes-sous-bois
il va voir le jour sur le parking public
situé à côté du marché actuel est les
travaux viennent de démarrer pour un an
l'objectif c'est de proposer un marché
modernisé avec une nouvelle halle afin
de reconquérir les clients beaucoup ont
déserté les lieux à cause de la vétusté
en attendant la livraison de ce marché
flambant neuf les commerçants ont été
déplacés sur l'avenue maurice jouets
vous pouvez les retrouver sur place le
dimanche matin
le portrait de la semaine c'est
maintenant
[Musique]
direction la vallée de chevreuse pour
faire la connaissance de fabien thibout
jeunes cuisiniers des yvelines il est
tombé dans la passion pour la
restauration depuis ses 14 ans nous
sommes allés le rencontrer au moment de
la préparation de l'une de ses recettes
fétiches une rencontre signée jules
colis originaires de cerner la ville le
jeune cuisinier fabien thibout est ce
qu'on peut appeler un pur produit de la
vallée de chevreuse
il a commencé la cuisine à l'âge de 14
ans avec un bac professionnel
restauration en alternance aux écuries
du château à dampierre ainsi qu'aux clos
de chevreuse fabien ensuite passé une
mention complémentaire en dessert à
l'assiette
avant de se lancer dans la vie
professionnelle après c'est à des
formations en fait j'ai essayé de me
diriger vers le métier mon père qui est
la charcuterie et charcutiers traiteurs
j'ai été travaillé chez un collègue à
lui qu'à paris 16ème qui est monsieur
geôliers avaient entouré france suite à
des essais dans le monde du traiteur
c'est une expérience un peu particulière
qui en 2014 va ramener fabien vers la
restauration avec mon école ont été
invités à participer à ce salon de la
restauration dans ce salon là il y avait
un concours le concours jean de l'aven
ce concours là je les fais avec mathieu
des mares s'ils avaient vraiment les
chefs qui était mieux en valeur et aussi
les commis par le biais d'un prix en
fête du meilleur commis qui j'ai
remporté c'est vrai que je me cache pas
de le mettre sur mon cv c'est un vrai
atout et après ça mais quand même une
pression supplémentaire parce quand un
patron qui m'engage en sachant je suis
premier commis il va s'attendre à
vraiment d'excellence donc ça me donne
encore plus envie de donner un savoir
faire qu'il nous présente avec la
composition d'une entrée cher à son
coeur dans un lieu tout aussi important
donc aujourd'hui on est dans la cuisine
de mes parents de la charcuterie de
chevreuse et j'ai passé énormément de
temps ça soit les dimanches jeunes aider
mes parents ou même des entraînements
pour moi même quand j'avais envie de
perfectionner les quelques recettes ou
des trucs comme ça c'est un côté en fait
vachement pratique
alors aujourd'hui je vais vous présenter
une recette que j'ai appris justement
chez monsieur pascal joly qui s'appelle
un délice de krav donc ça va être une
macédoine ces zones et avec une
mayonnaise citron un guacamole juste un
petit peu épicée une crème au crabe en
dessus dans une verrine j'aimerais bien
travailler à l'étranger pour apprendre
d'autres cultures de techniques et
ouvrir un restaurant en tant que chef
pâtissier que ce soit ici ou ailleurs
le top du top ce serait d'ouvrir en fait
en vallée de chevreuse un parcours
inspirant que ce futur chef cuisinier
continue d'écrire chaque jour en
travaillant notamment dans les cuisines
de la prestigieuse abbaye des vaux de
cernay
on continue à parler de l'artisanat avec
mon deuxième invité dans ce journal
olivier devaux bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
le nouveau directeur du cfa de la
chambre des métiers de l'artisanat des
yvelines ce centre de formation des
apprentis est situé à versailles et a
depuis peu des locaux rénovés qu'est-ce
qui a été rénové dans ses locaux
c'est vrai nous allons profiter de mes
vacances d'été de l'arrêt pour rénover
l'ensemble des ateliers tous les
plateaux techniques de plus de 5000
euros de travaux financés par des
organismes professionnels les
fédérations et la région qui nous ont
permis de reprendre en totalité le
plateau des esthéticiennes ce qui nous
permet de mettre en place de nouvelles
formations puisque on ouvre un bts
esthétique cette année la boucherie
également entièrement rénové et là aussi
nous mettons en place un nouveau brevet
professionnel boucherie la pâtisserie et
la boulangerie et qui ont reçu des
équipements entièrement rénové donc le
gros travaux pendant l'été qui nous
permettent d'ouvrir avait dans de bonnes
conditions
les chambre de fermentation je crois
pour l'avion vers les fermentations
absolument vous êtes bien renseigné qui
sont nécessaires pour pour la pâte pour
qu'elle puisse le lez des sables se
lever dans de bonnes conditions et là on
est des équipements tout à fait au top
on précise que le cfa dvd locaux voilà
qui datait qui date des années 70
pourquoi c'était nécessaire de de faire
ces rénovations
alors c'est vrai ce cfa est bien connue
de tous les versailles et et de tous les
artisans des yvelines le bâtiment le
bâti a peu évolué et d'ailleurs c'est le
prochain le prochain projet il faut
maintenant qu'on s'attaque à la
structure commet
des ateliers eux sont rénovés très
régulièrement nous sommes soutenus par
les fédérations par la région pour les
maintenir à niveau et et là nous avons
profité de l'occasion du lancement de
nouvelles formations pour donner un bon
coup de collier sur la qualité technique
vous le disiez ce qui a rendu aussi
possible ces rénovations c'est des aides
de partenaires c'est ça absolument le
cfa ne serait rien sans les métiers rien
son artisanat et sans la région et qui
nous soutiennent très largement
si bien les fédérations professionnelles
comme je le disais que quel conseil
régional qu'est ce que ça change
concrètement da d'évoluer pour ses
élèves au sein de locaux rénovés ce
qu'ils travaillent dans de meilleures
conditions est ce que ça peut aussi
attirer de nouveaux élèves vers vers le
cfa alors nous avons fait une très bonne
rentrée puisque laisser happer sont
pratiquement au complet
bien sûr la qualité de l'enseignement
est importante je crois que ce qui est
le plus important dans une formation ce
sont les formateurs et les équipes sont
rodées songé vraiment puisque vous le
disais j'ai pris ce cfa cet été ses
récents mais j'ai découvert
d'excellentes équipes aussi bien
d'ailleurs parmi les formateurs que les
équipes de direction dont qui est très
impersonnel à la fois éprouvée anciens
pour beaucoup d'entre eux et avec une
très forte expérience mais il faut aussi
leur mettre à disposition des
équipements et c'était l'enjeu de cette
rénovation récente
l'autre actualité du cfa c'est que
désormais les formations sont regroupés
dans des pôles
il ya par exemple un pôle de métier de
bouche avec la boulangerie là où la
boucherie charcuterie la pâtisserie un
pôle soins du corps ça permet quoi c'est
d'être plus lisible sur l'offre de
formation
oui c'était tellement jeux récents en
fin d un enjeu important des évolutions
récentes
plusieurs sections ont été fermées ces
dernières années en mécanique automobile
en prothèse dentaire des fois des
métiers qui peut-être voyez leur avenir
un peu dans la prothèse dentaire par
exemple un peu fermé et puis qui était
un petit peu extérieur au coeur de nos
activités qui sont maintenant bien
recentrer sur l'alimentation et les
soins du corps et la logique maintenant
c'est d'offrir des parcours complet dans
ces filières donc nous offrons laisser
happer sur l'ensemble des métiers en
boucherie en boulangerie en pâtisserie
en cuisine et pour les soins du corps en
esthétique et en coiffure mais nous
montons maintenant donc laisser happer
au niveau 5
nous ouvrons les brevets professionnels
dans l'ensemble des filières la
boulangerie sera la dernière année
ouvrira donc une section en brevet
professionnel boulangerie l'été prochain
ce qui nous permet d'augmenter au niveau
4 et puis nous commençons à regarder sur
le niveau 3 puisqu'on a ouvert cette
année un bts en esthétique et ça c'est
peut-être une ambition plus à moyen
terme et il serait intéressant là aussi
de poursuivre les cursus dans les autres
filières et le niveau 3 au niveau 3
c'est-à-dire on est maintenant dans le
supérieur l'a compris et l'offre assez
large qui est à la fois à la rejetterait
cohérence très cohérent qu est-ce qu en
offrant comme ça ces parcours
un jeune qui après la 3e souhaite
poursuivre sa formation par
l'apprentissage est une voie de
formation différente mais qui est aussi
une voie de formation diplômante pourra
venir chez nous au ca penny vos 5 puis
ensuite poursuivre avec un brevet
professionnel niveau bac et
éventuellement poursuivre dans le
supérieur avec des bts et en même temps
il pourra faire des passerelles avec des
mentions complémentaires donc on peut
oser assurer une formation très complète
et dans la durée et ça aux bénéfices
évidemment de l'artisanat du département
vous le disiez vous avez pris vos
fonctions
cet été vous avez était auparavant en
charge de la formation professionnelle
au sein de la marine nationale est ce
que cette expérience vous conter la
mettre à profit pour pour développer le
cfa continuer le développement du cfa
c'est vrai je vous remercie de rappeler
ce détail qui n'est pas tout à fait un
détail puisque j'ai passé quelques
années comme comme marin où je me suis
occupé de formation professionnelle ou
de la formation
anciennement m'a passionné alors on dira
c'est complètement différent en fait pas
tout à fait car les jeunes qui nous
rejoignent qui rejoignent la marine
sur lui ce n'est plus sont finalement
les mêmes que ceux qui aujourd'hui
choisissent de faire un métier dans
l'artisanat les mêmes en ce sens qu'ils
sortent du collège ou du lycée recherche
d'une voie nous les formons dans la
marine je les forme aujourd'hui dans
l'artisanat les principes de la
pédagogie de la préparation d'un diplôme
du développement d'un savoir être tous
ces principes sont les mêmes
après les plateaux techniques sont
différents mais mais c'est la même
passion pour pour offrir un avenir à la
jeunesse
ces artisans on a bien sûr besoin les
professions de l'artisanat ont un bel
avenir devant elle oui oui j'en suis
persuadé il ya un vrai regain d'intérêt
pour l'artisanat
ce sont des métiers qui n'ont jamais
cessé d'offrir leurs services
en étant présent dans l'alimentation de
la coiffure on est là sur des métiers
qui sont à la fois ancien traditionnel
mais qui ont un bel avenir devant eux il
ya un regain d'intérêt pour la qualité
des produits et un regain d'intérêt pour
l'esthétique et pour les soins du corps
et tout ça offre un véritable avenir aux
jeunes qui souhaiteront de nous
construire d'un ancien de voir les
quelles sont les perspectives notamment
pour le cfa vous le disiez vous arrivez
encore attiré de nombreux jeunes oui je
le disais nous avons fait le plein avec
laisser happer cette année il reste
quelques places en coiffure quelques
toutes petites places en boucherie elles
se comptent sur les doigts d'une main
les autres ces appels sont complets
il reste quelques places dans les
brevets professionnels quelques places
au bts esthétique également mais c'est
une vraie satisfaction puisqu'on voit
que les nos formations trouvent trouve
de l'intérêt et trouve aussi parce que
c'est très important c'est ce qu'on
oublie avec la tête parfois avec
l'apprentissage trouve des employeurs
c'est à dire qu'un jeune qui vient chez
nous en apprentissage chez qui l'a
d'abord un contrat dans une entreprise
et c'est un point que qu'il est
important de souligner c'est que
l'apprentissage chez un lien continu
entre l'entreprise l'employeur et le
centre de formation le centre de
formation prépare le diplôme et
l'entreprise offre la base de la
compétence et c'est cette
complémentarité est donc ce tissu très
très dense entre les entrepreneurs du
département le centre de formation qui
vraiment offre la qualité de formation
et toute cette offre de formation la
retrouve sur le site internet du cfa qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran merci
olivier devaux d'avoir été avec nous
merci recteur de ce cfa de la chambre
des métiers et de l'artisanat qui est
situé à versailles du sport les
meilleurs athlètes du monde de la
discipline à 50 ans on y vit le
vélodrome nationale accueille à partir
de demain la première manche de la coupe
du monde de cyclisme sur piste
u6 jusqu'à dimanche c'est la première
fois dans sa jeune histoire que
l'enceinte yvelinoise reçoit cette
compétition elle 25 pays seront
représentés plus de 250 pistard présents
parmi lesquels bien sûr ceux de l'équipe
de france les confirmé françois pervis
et grégory baugé mais aussi la jeune
génération incarnée notamment par
mathilde de gros et sébastien vigier
propos recueillis par patrick jacques de
dixmude et miquel et demi d'euros
on est sur des courses de très haut
niveau
après on est dans le contexte de la
qualification pour les jeux olympiques
de tokyo 2020 donc ces deux
la coupe de france qui à la coupe du
monde de 50 ha est le deuxième événement
donc sur une série de 16 qui sont
qualificatifs donc nous français sont en
forme
nos français sont bons coureurs enfin
spécialement donc sur dans les
catégories de sprint donc oui c'est
vraiment un grand événement qui va avoir
lieu dans le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines première
manche de la coupe du monde à partir de
demain et jusqu'à dimanche au vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
culture à rambouillet où un véritable
bestiaire a investi la salle patenôtre
jusqu'au 21 octobre la ville propose sa
13e et biennale de la sculpture
animalière du bronze à la terre cuite
plus d'une centaine de créations est à
découvrir découverte justement avec
mélanie poké il rugit imposant tous deux
lames d'acier
ce gardien semble protéger ses
congénères depuis le 7 octobre l'animal
s'expose à rambouillet pour la treizième
biennale de la sculpture rambouillet
situé dans au milieu d'une forêt dans
lequel on a beaucoup d'animaux il ya une
tradition animalière à rambouillet
depuis fort longtemps et c'est cette
tradition là que nous avons souhaité
conserver
avec cette exposition liée aux animaux
en particulier
de l'animal domestique l animal sauvage
des oeuvres discrète d'autres monumental
la biennale rassemble un véritable
bestiaire où toutes les techniques sont
représentées
quarante trois artistes exposent plus
d'une centaine d'oeuvres
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous ouvrons notre biennale à la fois
aux artistes amateurs et professionnels
donc il n'ya pas de discrimination entre
les deux et ce sont des artistes qui
viennent de
la d'ile-de-france de rambouillet d'île
de france mais aussi de province on a
des gens qui viennent du sud de la
france de marseille on a des artistes
qui viennent aussi de l'est de l'ouest
de la france et on a aussi quelques
étrangers qui expose elle les animaux
sont à rambouillet jusqu'au 21 octobre
avant de prendre leur envol
[Musique]
avant de vous quitter de demain à
dimanche ce sont les journées nationale
d'architecturé une visite-conférence du
théâtre national de saint quentin en
yvelines est programmée samedi à 14h30
bâtiment emblématique du territoire
imaginé par l'architecte stanislas
viseur il a été livré en 1993 marquant
l'achèvement de la ville nouvelle
pour cette visite conférence animée par
l'architecte une réservation est
conseillée et d'autres idées de sorties
loisirs sont à retrouver dans l'émission
7 8 loisirs justement présentés un par
marylène iapichino c'est la fin du set 8
journal belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]